tiempo de hablar de economía en 324 y
estamos para eso con daniela blandón que
nos va a contar lo más importante de
esta jornada ni la bienvenida y
empezamos hablando del desempleo en
méxico que está cediendo aunque aumenta
la informalidad así es liliana mire la
tasa de desempleo en este país cayó en
el primer semestre a niveles que se
acercan a la cifra de antes de pandemia
que era del 35 por ciento en junio fue
del 4% de la población económicamente
activa las estadísticas muestran que 6,5
millones de personas han retornado al
mercado laboral pero todavía queda un
millón que no se ha reincorporado
después de la pandemia lo que sí está
creciendo con fuerza es la ocupación
informal que hoy tiene una tasa del 55,4
por ciento
esto es 2,3 puntos más que hace un año y
que significa que unos 35 millones de
personas no cuentan con un empleo formal
otra de las características del mercado
laboral mexicano liliana es que cerca de
la mitad de la población gana menos de
dos salarios mínimos
vayamos ahora a argentina que decretó la
emergencia hídrica en una de sus
principales fuentes fluviales esta
emergencia hídrica estará vigente a
partir de este lunes en siete provincias
debido al histórico descenso en el nivel
de las aguas del río paraná que es clave
para sus ventas externas esta es la vía
fluvial por la que sale el 80% de las
exportaciones de granos y derivados de
ese país que es una de las grandes
despensas del mundo pero debido a una
prolongada escasez de agua en su cuenca
en el sur de brasil el río está en su
nivel más bajo en 77 años no sólo se
están afectando las exportaciones
también el abastecimiento de agua
potable las operaciones del puerto y la
generación de energía eléctrica entre
otros la emergencia va a estar vigente
por 180 días liliana daniela este martes
inicia un juicio político un juicio
histórico perdón por delitos financieros
en el vaticano y la historia es que la
protagonista el mayor juicio penal en la
historia moderna del vaticano el
cardenal ángelo beccio de 73 años
es el antiguo jefe de la secretaria de
estado quien se convierte en el de mayor
rango en ser juzgado por fraude al menos
a una decena de personas o una decena de
personas son acusadas de desangrar a la
santa sede- con miles de millones de
dólares a través de malas inversiones y
aparentes favores amigos entre ellos
están corredores de bolsa y abogados que
burlaron al 'número dos' de la santa
sede para que firmara un polémico
acuerdo de bienes raíces sobre todo una
empresa inmobiliaria londinense de 350
millones de dólares también está un auto
denominada analista de inteligencia que
compró artículos de prada y de louis
vuitton con dinero de los fieles
daniela y en diez años ya no habría siga
ríos tradicionales en gran bretaña lo
dijo el presidente ejecutivo de philip
morris international que es la compañía
que fabrica los cigarrillos marlboro él
fue citado por el diario británico mail
on sunday diciendo que en los próximos
diez años la compañía tabacalera va a
desaparecer de los estantes británicos
sus cigarrillos tradicionales de esta
manera pondría
a más de un siglo de relación con el
país y esto va en línea con una ambición
más amplia del país de acabar con el
tabaquismo para 2030 el siglo de la
compañía dijo que quiere permitir que
esta empresa o sea philip morris deje de
fumar y advierte que el futuro está es
en los cigarrillos electrónicos bueno y
vamos ahora con los indicadores de la
jornada ni la uv o triple recorta en
wall street en medio de la expectativa
por los resultados trimestrales de las
grandes tecnológicas que se presentan
esta semana y también a la espera de una
nueva reunión de la reserva federal
entre martes y miércoles que podría
arrojar pistas sobre las perspectivas de
la economía en el corto plazo
américa latina siguió la misma tendencia
y la bolsa de buenos aires logró
ganancias tras dos ruedas consecutivas
en negativo y finalizamos con la cifra
del día daniela mil millones de dólares
liliana las ganancias trimestrales de la
fabricante de autos de lujo tesla
superaron por primera vez esa cifra con
lo que extiende una racha de prosperidad
de dos años las utilidades entre
y junio representan casi 10 veces más de
lo que ganó hace un año lo sorprendente
es la capacidad que ha tenido la empresa
del excéntrico hilo en moscú para
navegar por una creciente escasez de
chips que ha causado grandes dolores de
cabeza a los fabricantes de automóviles
del mundo
daniela por la información de colombia y
a usted gracias por estar entradas 24
recuerden que pueden ampliar la
información en nuestra página web
france24 puntocom y información en
cuatro idiomas del acontecer
internacional nos vemos más adelante
[Música]